- He's an American, former,
major league short stop
who, played 20 seasons
with the New York Yankees.
He's won five World Series championships
and is considered one
of the greatest players
of his generation.
He's finished six all time and career hits
and first among short stops.
He's Derek Jeter.
And here are his top
ten rules for success.
- One thing I've always
prioritized you know,
my number one priortiy
for the last 20 years,
was my baseball career.
That's it.
I did a lot of other things,
but I never waivered from
that being my number one goal.
I'm always diggin', setting goals
and trying to reach those goals
and working hard
and there's steps along the way
so I think prioritizing
is the number one thing.
Sometimes people have
so many different goals
that go in this direction,
that direction and they
never reach the potential
of one particular avenue
that they're going so, I
mean throughout my career
I've been very involved
in different businesses
and marketing and foundation
but my number one priority
is always the game and now
my priority's changed so
I can focus on some other things.
- [Announcer] Popped up
short center, Jeter out.
Canole and did Jeter catch it?
Wow, what a miraculous catch!
(crowd cheering)
unbelievable.
- I've always focused on work ethic.
You know I've always been
taught there's always going to
be someone that's better,
but there's no reason
why someone should outwork you.
And I think that applies not
only to sports but it applies
to anything that you try to do.
You have to work harder than
other people if you want
to be the best.
Never be satisfied.
You know I am never satisfied
I always try to think of
what I could do next to be better.
- [Announcer] Giel into
left field well hit.
Track, wall, off the top of
the wall into third is Perez,
they bring him around,
throw to the plate by Jeter,
quick throw into Novo.
- You have to win here,
that's the bottom line is
what have you done lately?
You know we were able to
accomplish a lot of good things
early on, we've been post
season every year so far but
the bottom line is when you're
competing you want to win.
I mean that's why you're out there.
Finishing second, finishing
third, going to the
post season's not good enough.
I think everyone should
have that mentality,
I mean you go into a season,
you win a championship,
or it doesn't mean anything.
- Have you always had
that kind of mentality,
even before you got to New York?
Or did it
- No question, no I was younger
I always wanted, my
daddy used to beat me at
everything we did.
- [Interviewer] He wouldn't let you win?
- No, no he wouldn't let
me win so now I don't let
anyone else win.
So I've always had that
mentality, it's pointless
from my point of view if you're
competing and you don't win.
(crowd cheering)
- [Announcer] And the two oh.
There it is!
(crowd cheering)
for 72 years, Lou Gherig has
been the Yankee's all time
hits leader, now it's Derek Jeter.
- Family they're the ones that,
I have a very close family.
They've always been very
supportive, more importantly
they've always been very honest.
I think a lot of times people
in general like to surround
themselves with people that
are going to tell them that
everything they're doing is right.
You know what I mean, you
need people around you
that are going to tell
you you're doing wrong.
And my parents are very very
honest, even if I don't want
to hear something, they'll
tell me, they'll give me
their opinion so I'd say
family is most important and
then secondly your friends.
It's the same thing I think
your friends are the ones
that are going to help ya,
they're the ones that are going to
support you, at times they're
going to be the ones that
get you in trouble, so
you have to make sure that
you surround yourself with
a good group of friends.
- [Announcer] And no one long,
a high pop, off third foul,
(inaudible) and Jeter
there, Jeter makes the catch
and falls into the crowd.
And he's out.
They gave him the out call
and Grosser now throws
to second, and now time is
called, and I don't know
what the ruling is.
Chavez went to second 'cause
Jeter was in the crowd.
And Jeter now climbs out of
the crowd, but Derek Jeter
made an unbelievable catch
and as he hit with his waist
on the railing down the third
base line, he back flipped
into the crowd and held
onto the ball, what a catch
by Derek Jeter.
What a play.
- I learned something from
watching Mr. Torrey for all
these years, you know you
always hear the phrase you
treat everyone the same,
well that's not correct,
you treat everyone fairly.
You try to be the same every
day, you don't come and
hold your head up high when
things are going well and
things are going bad
you find a way to hide.
Leadership I don't think is
something that's appointed,
I think it's something that's earned.
(crowd cheering)
- [Announcer] Jeter hits it
to right, back at the wall,
It's over, Yankees win
and the series is tied.
I have a lot of confidence,
I think you have to have
confidence in your ability.
The stronger you are
mentally I think the better
you're going to perform so
I've always had confidence
any time I'm in a situation
I tend to look back and
think back to times that
I had success and I think
that's helped me out throughout.
("Empire State of Mind" - Jay-Z)
- [Announcer] And toward the
hole, Jeter backhands from
the outfield.
(crowd cheering)
Man what a play!
- I'm fans of athletes from
all different sports, I've
never tried to emulate anyone else.
I've tried to be myself.
I've learned a lot of
watching guys, especially guys
when I was younger.
But I think in terms of
leadership, I think leadership
is viewed differently by
different people, I mean there's
people who lead by example,
there's people that are vocal
leaders, people that do
a little bit of both.
I think you just have to be who you are.
- How would you categorize
your leadership?
- Uh a little bit of both.
I really try to take the time
to get to know the people
that I'm leading, I think
that's most important.
I don't think you walk around
as a self proclaimed leader.
I think if you do things
the right way, you're honest
with people, people may
tend to follow but I don't
put on a show I don't do
things in front of the camera.
I've had plenty of conversations
with teammates behind
closed doors, you know I've
always heard you're not vocal,
he's just lead by example but
how would people know unless
they were behind closed doors?
So I have no problem with
that but like I said I think
the most important aspect
of leadership is getting
to know the people that you're leading.
- [Announcer] (inaudible) you're
not going to run you're not
going to hit, you got
to wait for a gapper.
(crowd cheering)
down the right field line,
Piazzi on his way to third,
and they're going to lead to
believe, the (inaudible)
(crowd cheering)
Derek Jeter, with one of
the most unbelievable plays
you will ever see by a shortstop.
- [Interviewer] What's your
message to kids nowadays that
are playing sports whether
it's baseball or any sport,
what's your message to the youth of today?
Have fun playing, you know
I think kids nowadays that
specialize in one particular
sport at such an early age
you know when I was younger,
we used to go outside
and play every game.
Now you don't really see
kids outside playing.
They're all inside playing video games.
Which there's a time and
a place for everything,
but I say go out and play
as many sports as you can,
be active and enjoy yourself, have fun.
You can't lose sight of
the fact that it is a game,
you're supposed to enjoy yourself.
- [Announcer] Meek deals.
Base hit to left field.
Here comes Richardson, here's
the throw from Ortegas,
Richardson is safe!
Derek Jeter ends his final
game with a walk off single.
Derek Jeter, where
fantasy becomes reality.
Did you have any doubt?
- How was Dave Winfield an inspiration?
Dave was, for those of you
who didn't know, I think he's
the only athelete to be drafted
and called three sports.
For anyone here who thinks
they've ever been an athlete,
you can't compare to Dave.
But he was an inspiration
maybe because he was one
of the first athletes to
start his own foundation.
That's the idea the inspiration
of my own foundation,
because when I was younger
I read up on Dave, I wanted
to be like him.
(crowd cheering)
- [Announcer] One two.
He loops out to left field,
it'll be a tough play,
Jeter on the run, makes the play.
And flies into the stands!
Oh what a play by Derek Jeter!
(crowd cheering)
Wow, Jeter really banged himself up.
- [Commentator] You can see
the redness in his face,
he caught the bar on that dive.
What a play!
- You're going to struggle,
that's the bottom line, I don't
care how good you are, you're
going to fail I mean you
fail seven out of 10 times,
you go to the Hall of Fame
you know what I mean.
I was talking to a group of
my leaders once and this was
right around the time I got
three thousand hits and I said
well I have three thousand
hits, but I've gotten out
seven thousand times,
you know what I mean?
(laughing)
It's not funny.
(laughter)
I don't think it's funny
but you get out quite a bit,
so I've always just tried to
remember the good times and
you have to have very short
memory and you have to stay
positive, but I don't
care what career you're in
you're going to fail.
You're going to have tough
times you know, people always
look at people when they're
successful and they assume
they just woke up and they
ended up in that position
but there's a lot of speed
bumps along the way, it's
just your job to try to
make that speed bump not
be a road block, you know what I mean?
But you have to learn from
your mistakes and move on
and stay positive and mistakes
I think you can learn more,
I always tend to learn
more from people's failures
than from their success.
I think you have that approach.
(crowd cheering)
("Empire State of Mind" - JayZ)
- Thank you guys so much for
watching, I made this video
because Jacob Rodriguez asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Derek Jeter's top 10
points you liked the most.
Leave it in the comments, I
will join in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for
watching, continue to believe
and I'll see you soon.